the latin letter z doesn't even appear
in russia's cyrillic alphabet but since
the start of the war in ukraine it's
gone from being a mysterious marking on
russian military vehicles to becoming a
recognizable pro-war symbol used to
express support of president putin and
the russian military
what's more the russian government has
begun merging this new symbol with the
orange and black stripes of a
centuries-old ribbon a ribbon that has
been loaded with military meaning
throughout russian history so where are
these symbols coming from and how is the
kremlin using them to drum up support
for the war
let's start with the z if you look at
russian signage or social media you'll
see it all over the place these days for
example this z post from the russian
military's instagram account appears
alongside the russian word for heroes
with a z added to the end other photos
appear to show russian soldiers flashing
the z with their hands when president
putin spoke at a rally in march zee was
featured in signs around him that read
for russia and for a world without
nazism we'll come back to that nazism
theme in a bit there are a lot of
theories about what the z means and
where it came from but my colleague
matthew luxmore who studied the use of
russian symbols says it's very likely
that it was just an easy to write
marking like a v or an o russia used it
to identify some of its military
equipment and then it spread it does
seem like it was kind of bottom up and
people started to write z's on their
cars because they wanted to express
their support for this campaign and then
very quickly it was seized on by the
government now that z has become a thing
you may notice it written with stripes
like this and that is not some organic
thing matthew says that is very
intentional this really really works it
resonates people people understand it
people have pride in this why are those
stripes significant you have to go back
a few centuries to find out
it turns out those stripes go back to
the 1700s at a time when russia was
expanding its empire and seizing parts
of what's now modern-day ukraine in 1769
catherine the great established russia's
highest military honor the order of
saint george
the really interesting thing about the
order in addition to its exclusivity is
the ribbon it's actually a point of some
contention among scholars where the
ribbon comes from but it's also the most
recognized ribbon and today
used for lots of different co-opted for
lots of different reasons history
professor russell martin says that over
time russians have used the ribbon of
saint george to rally around various
military achievements most prominently
it's become a symbol of the soviet
victory over the nazis in world war ii
something russia celebrates with a huge
victory day parade every may
in recent years the ribbon has also been
used to express support for the 2014
annexation of crimea from ukraine and
russia's military intervention in the
donbas region for some it's going to
have a
general patriotic
purpose but for
for most and since 2014 especially it
really does have to do with russia's
military greatness it has
association
in the with in the past with expansion
and that's where the ribbon of saint
george and the z come together over the
years president putin and his supporters
have seized on this idea that russia
continues to fight nazism fascism and
threats from the west and now putin is
using this same idea to justify the
bloody invasion of ukraine that's
playing out today
they're being ruled
as putin puts it by nazis neo-nazis and
fascists we need to save them from the
neo-nazis they they just don't realize
it themselves there's no evidence that
ukraine's government is run by neo-nazis
and ukraine's president volodomir
zielinski is jewish but as these russian
social media posts show the kremlin is
clearly merging the new symbol z with
the powerful symbolism of the ribbon of
saint george to try to tap into this
world war ii narrative that russia must
continue to defeat nazism that russia is
for victory those two things are being
put together to kind of conflate both
support for the armed forces and this
deep-rooted idea that somehow russia is
um
waging the same campaign and waged them
defending itself rather than invading
another country
yeah it's always said it's defending
itself as um hard that is to i guess
believe based on the evidence of course
not everyone buys this argument and some
have likened russia's z to the nazi
swastika for example ukraine's defense
minister posted this photo on twitter
showing a swastika-like symbol formed by
two z's and other comparisons of the z
and the swastika have been photographed
around the world in recent weeks now
that the z has been embraced by the
russian government ukraine's foreign
minister is calling on all states to
criminalize the use of z as a way to
publicly support the war
speaking of symbols the javelin has
become a symbol of the ukrainian
resistance check out this video to learn
more about what it is and how it's being
used on the battlefield and if you like
this video subscribe to the channel for
more stories like this i'll see you next
time